肌はのでじゃあ張り付いわけでただいま富山県のカターレ富山さんという対話県の
サッカーのチームなんですけども
同サッカー j 6の試合に来ております
というわけで今日僕がですねちょっと語るテーマさんの試合に反対のとかにベルんです
けど
もうん
どう簡単におらされるぞちょっと軽い企画的なものをしようと思いますね大して
はず目立つを父ハンガー
[音楽]
というわけでお二人には今日一日中歩き回っております
ず簡単に説明すると僕が何かしらの何かしらで2ず危ないに隠れていますねそれの
パターンがなくあります
まぁこ時間によって変わるので見つけて下さい
7種類の源さん断捨離の僕がどこかさらにいますそれはひょっとしたらスタジアムの中
かもしれねえパパ
屋台の人かもしれないなぁ方またたかもしれないというちょっといろんな状況があると
思うのでそれを二人に頑張って
ぶーぶーっ
またねパパに頑張るん
デコ簡単ねつまりは難しいやつもあるんでスたり
どれだけでおけるかヒントとしてお客さんに僕がバレてもそれがヒントになると思うの
でないこと
お客さんにもバレずにいればいいなと思いますでは
ね多いですよね a re
me
というわけで jmh 警備員です
見えますです多分通すだけだからそれだけ
しますいやー時ドケスねーなんか
版ましたじゃあも入ることにしていっ
me
aname
[音楽]
我々ん
car
me
大変一大隊でも在タイラスヨもソメっちゃったよりなさそうだしている
働いてるよあればいざカー
ん
[音楽]
me
これぞ身長以外は大丈夫です1丁だけかするとそれは
[音楽]
えーっわっ
ni
me
[音楽]
bejean
お前難しい
始めたなぁ
[音楽]
ん
サッカーのしなりといえば仕分けのコンディションがとても重要になってきます
yeah
rar
jr ん
お願いします
[音楽]
白い
そして綺麗
ああああああ
ni ん
[音楽]
ん
ぶうううう
[音楽]
masaki さん宅皆さんがこっち見てください
ありがとうございます
ズボン
んの
反射区にらしい jリーグ言える丈夫です
ni
then
はいですけどねだ絶対強盗かと気分になってると分
5位急がないとの結果じゃないと思うん
me
car
wh
tame ni
みんなの力で
ああああああああ
[音楽]
me
wh
ええええええ
me
ana
[音楽]
tl 著 tee
uh
ああああああ
car
rar
nosai demande
はーい
yeah
お願いします
ファッション
衛兵
寝すぎないんです
[音楽]
どんどん
dj nao
ban
me
いいいいいいい
[音楽]
me
car bomb いい
yeah yeah
ni
car
mar
自然な場にいないと思う
naa うおっん
あああ
kono ai
ani
ni
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
car
えってもらえなかっで打っておらいろは